the National Security Agency knew about
the Internet's heartbleed bug for two
years but instead of telling the public
decided to use the flawda gather
intelligence Bloomberg News reporter
Mike Riley broke this story and joins me
right now from Washington Mike tell me
how did this all work so this is
actually with the NSA does they find
they have more than a thousand people
whose job it is to really look at
software code and especially really
important software code that covers a
lot of the Internet what they're looking
for is flaws they're looking for
vulnerabilities that they can use that
they're hackers can use to get into
computers if you can't rass that with
the open open source security community
they have a small number of researchers
who who spent a lot of trying time
trying to maintain the integrity of the
code and they just missed this one the
NSA did not so they totally missed it I
mean what does that tell us about our
own ability to regulate and prevent
these kinds of things from happening and
I think this is a really important
moment in people's awareness of Internet
Security I mean one of the things that
that we know is that code has flaws in
it and that those flaws are used by
hackers to access our sensitive
information the the most motivated
people on the planet to find those flaws
and to use them our intelligence
agencies not just the NSA but China's
Intelligence Agency Russia's
Intelligence Agency Israel's
Intelligence Agency they devote a huge
amount of resources to do this they have
a lot of equipment they have a lot of
very sophisticated techniques they will
look and they will find these
vulnerabilities probably not given what
we know so far after the Snowden leaks
about the the depth and breadth of the
NSA's surveillance capabilities it's
probably not a surprise that they found
this particular bug especially since one
of the things we now know about it was
it really wasn't that hard to find if
you were looking in the right place
there just weren't the right people
looking in the right place all right
Mike thank you very much for more on
this I want to bring in ghostery senior
director of research Andy call if you
remember former NSA contractor and
Snowden spoke just this past month at
out by southwest and he actually
recommended using gostrey to prevent
organizations and companies from
tracking your online browser preferences
well that's an interesting endorsement
yeah yeah that was pretty good pretty
good we were happy happy that he thought
of us that way all right so to explain
to me what gostrey actually does and how
it protects your identity online so
every time you visit a website there's a
myriad of companies that are trying to
track your activity to see what you
might be interested in so that they can
mainly so they can advertise to you
later so a pretty robust profile of you
can be built just based on your browsing
activities in your browsing history so
what gostrey does is it shows you all of
this stuff that's happening mostly in
the background most of it's completely
invisible we show you all the stuff
that's happening and we allow you to
block that interaction if you'd like
okay um and so they can't tell who's
actually behind the IP address it
actually hides it that well yeah so what
anytime the you visit a website there
has to be code on the site that actually
phones home and shares things like your
IP address what you're reading the other
information about your computer we just
interrupt that code from ever leaving
your browser so it's it's you know you
sort of never come home in the first
place what's it cost to do this it's
absolutely free so great yeah so the way
we support ourselves is that our users
can opt in to share information with us
about the data collectors that they
encounter it's an anonymous panel so we
don't track our users because that would
be counterproductive interesting but I
remain can't come to you and say we need
to know who that was we take a lot of
steps to anonymize all of our data so
that even if anybody were to try to mine
it there wouldn't be anything I gotta
ask you that you know on the one hand
yeah privacy is great on the other hand
if you're someone who's up to no good um
it might be nice that someone could
actually track you down sure well for
our perspective it's not a matter of
saying that more or less data is a good
or bad thing I mean I think we're all
moving into places where you know we
wear devices that sort of quantify our
life and we do a lot on our phones that
collect a lot of data about us but we
just think it should be a transparent
process where you should know what
you're getting into when you're getting
into it okay you should know what you're
getting into when you get into it um how
explain to me your business model
and overall how are you so we take that
anonymous data and sites and brands will
buy reports from us to help them audit
the relationships with these data
collection tools so there ostensibly
there to help them sort of measure their
audience and help them advertise better
but it can get out of hand for for them
as well so we help them manage that sort
of cloud of marketing technologies that
they have okay um what's the future for
you guys then in this age of increasing
need for privacy I think there is an
enormous amount of work that needs to be
done in terms of making sure that users
are really understand the kinds of data
they're sharing and what it's used for I
think that we can get to a place where
people are comfortable about sharing
data if they really understand exactly
how it's being used you know later in
the future yeah I mean that I mean I
think that's everybody's sort of
concerned here how much data really can
be collected on all of us right and as
long as I understand what it is I may be
willing to make the trade off like if
it's a scenario where you're going to do
better job sort of giving it giving the
advertisements that I'm interested in
okay maybe I'm okay with that but if
it's a scenario where you're sharing
information about my you know personal
health or browsing habits with the
government or something like that that
may be something that I want to stem on
my end all right um overall do you think
we're gonna continue to see this be a
bigger and bigger issue I mean ed
Snowden are we gonna hear much much more
in the coming months absolutely i mean
there's a there's sort of a movable you
know an unstoppable force against an
immovable object which is we're all
sharing more and more and more as as you
know technology allows us to quantify
our lives more and more and more so the
there's going to be more data out there
right to use and so we're certainly
going to continue here on your mind no
big debate yeah look I think anytime
anybody makes it more transparent that's
a good thing so absolutely yeah